from tipguest.com seven and ten
Independents are worried about Biden's
mental Fitness worried about how about
convinced there is none he doesn't have
mental Fitness
they say a new poll is found that nearly
seven in ten registered Independents are
worried about President Joe Biden's
mental Fitness ahead of the 2024
election this is NPR PBS NewsHour Marist
published on Wednesday found that 69
percent of richer Independents believe
his mental Fitness is a genuine concern
while 27 believe his mental Fitness is
being used as a campaign strategy by
opponents I love this because the way
you frame a question always matters if I
were to ask the average person do you
think Joe Biden's brain is broken I bet
70 say yes
if you were then ask him is it a concern
seventy percent say yes you see how they
do this
yeah
I can't imagine how people can have any
kind of awareness of the president and
not say Well it kind of you know
listen to him you know I mean that's
that's your standard kind of the reply
that you would expect from the average
person that doesn't pay a whole lot of
attention to to politics if you've only
got
you know if you dedicate 15 minutes a
day to watching a little bit of news so
that way you feel like you have an idea
about what people are talking about and
you hear Joe Biden
twice a week
you can't feel confident that this guy's
you know laser focused on what's going
on
I I can't imagine how that is and
obviously it's showing in the in the
polls yeah I mean I I just don't know
how you could have seen Joe Biden say
anything in public and not be worried
about the status of his mental health
the best the best the man does at public
speaking is
slurring his words instead of constantly
gaffing I remember when we watched his
State of the Union Address about a year
and a half ago and it was probably the
best he'd sounded in the last year and a
half but he did sound drunk the entire
time not saying he was drunk I'm just
saying his brain operates in such a way
that when he speaks normally he slurs
his words to the point where he sounds
intoxicated I think that one of the one
of the negatives about the way that the
Twitter space went today is I don't see
a convincing
argument to get the president on a
Twitter space had this gone perfectly
and it been great and and had everything
worked fine then you could all then you
could argue okay we have to get the you
know get more presidential uh candidates
on the more you get the more pressure it
is on Trump and and Biden
um I would like to see that happen but I
feel like that was probably the biggest
uh the biggest negative about this is
the fact that it's it's it doesn't lend
credibility to Independent Media and
stuff the way that that I had hoped that
it would well Joe Biden would benefit
from this like FDR did there is no way
Joe Biden yeah
I mean we're watching wander around
stage for an hour but I mean this is
like I was thinking about this today
what greater you know this is the BLM
crossover here
what greater vision of white privilege
could possibly exist than the media and
everyone else covering for Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden like literally they've been
trying to indoctrinate our kids
they haven't tried all of society
basically on this false notion of white
privilege and you've got an old guy in
there that just wanders around stage
they run you know cover for him the
entire time his son is like literally
the worst
presidential kid ever to exist in the
history should be in jail for the rest
of his life and this isn't why they're
not talking about white privilege now
this is crazy it's a wild thing he's
like he's like the ultimate nepo baby
that's ever existed seriously yeah and
so is Joe Biden though Joe Biden is
benefiting from like the nepotistic
elements of media where like they're
covering for him because he can't
literally conduct himself in a public
setting it's crazy yeah Hunter Biden is
really a remarkable character he is he
is a caricature of what Republicans
suspected a democratic President's child
could get away with like really smoking
crack that sounds like a joke yeah right
the man got on national television and
said he has spent more time picking
through the carpet for anything that
even remotely resembles crack cocaine
that he smoked more parmesan cheese than
anyone you know
and that's not even talking about his
dad's mental health yeah his dad's
mental health should be disqualifying
and completely remember when uh Nancy
Pelosi Was preparing the 25th Amendment
committee or whatever and everyone's
like it's for Trump and then they went
wait no it's provided yeah yeah I mean
the man is but that's white privilege my
friends I mean the guy is getting away
with like like the the kill shot White
Privilege out of the left we should be
demanding they hold themselves
accountable to White Privilege at this
point since they spent so much time on
it just embrace the white privilege
narrative but focus on Joe Biden just
focus on Joe Biden yeah just use it
against them to destroy it that could
help someone like the vague ramaswami
but then those black but Trump's an old
white man too it's like all right well
then why don't you talk smack about both
of them yeah but but the real is the
left doesn't like Joe Biden anyway
Liberals are the ones who vote for him
but I don't think anybody actually likes
him I think they're just like we'll take
any warm body over Donald Trump yeah
you're right though he wrote that
article yeah evictions focused like
exclusively on this kind of stuff well
he's totally it's his campaign he's
totally opposed to it yeah so so that's
why I should focus on it you should take
advantage of it yeah and be like I'm
going to win because you're going to
you're going to demand that I win and
then I'm going to change the laws and
take away the ability of this happen
again that'd be great in the meantime we
have to hope that Joe Biden doesn't
accidentally like press the button or
something right well I don't think well
yeah yeah that wouldn't even be that
much of a scam they would try to spin
that too like it was a mostly peaceful
nuking and I I bet Kamala Harris is the
actual president
because he keeps calling her president
Kamala I think it's far more likely that
Barack Obama's phoning it in then Kamala
Harris is doing it
I I'm deathly scared you know being the
Arizona here I'm deathly afraid of
this concept of potentially Kirsten
Cinema replacing Kamala Harris
what do you mean
I just there's something really funny
going on in Arizona you mean like
yourself runs Cinema is going to be the
she doesn't have a real shot I don't
think right running for Senate just like
the pathway is not there unless like
there's just like something that's
totally crazy
so it's like what is she doing like what
she has way too much money she's loved
by the Chamber of Commerce she's loved
by The Establishment Goons uh I'm really
afraid that they're gonna just like do
this like this the switcheroo the
swapparoo right and involve her in some
way that because again you have to look
at the map you guys have talked about it
here you talked about with Charlie which
is part of what we talk about it's
Arizona Wisconsin Georgia is everything
yeah so like getting Arizona taken care
of basically takes the map off the table
for the Republican and then people hate
Harris they despise her they put in a
cinema and she's lukewarm yeah but a lot
of people will be like okay well Biden's
incompetent but Cinemas you know she's
cool whatever right yeah and then I
wonder if you have to have a DeSantis
just because
Trump I don't think Trump can change his
standing with the American people you
either like him or you don't some people
are probably four they're either Forest
policies or they're not I think enough
people would be in favor of trump at
this point but he's got maximum name
recognition everybody knows and so if
descendants is an opportunity or
something new I think he kind of blew it
today but I still think he can recover
yeah
yeah I mean there's a long a lot of time
left here but you know it's an eternity
it I mean at this point I heard someone
talking about it today at this point in
the 2008 campaign it was Rudy Giuliani
and Hillary Clinton that were obviously
going to be the uh the the people that
were Giuliani they thought that yeah at
this point this far out they were they
said that Giuliani and Clinton and no
one could figure out you know it was
like obvious and blah blah and then this
young senator from uh Illinois
popped his head up and and the whole
world changed so oh man Hillary was so
pissed yeah she was her turn I love it
and then Obama beat her yeah they didn't
have their ducks on a row at the DNC yep
well they still don't I guess
they don't have I don't know if anybody
actually in government has their ducks
in her I'll be at you know the
committees or the Pacs or the campaigns
the parties it's all just insane
nonsense well the DNC will control
controls the process now after that
happened
that's why Bernie came the DNC the DNC
has had their finger on the federal
government has has had their finger on
the the scale for the DNC definitely
since brocco or since uh since um Donald
Trump was elected like Donald Trump
beating Hillary Clinton was not supposed
to happen and after that then federal
government has had their finger on the
on the scale as much as they can they
have been they have been pumping out as
much propaganda to all of the the Legacy
Media uh establishments that they can
that they that will take it
um so the government looked at Donald
Trump and said this is a really bad
thing and it's been doing its best to
make sure that Donald Trump can't get
elected again so
well a lot of that comes down to the
unpreparedness that the Democrats had in
Michigan which again you want to bring
up things that will never happen again
they will never let Michigan
slide out of their hands again it would
take a whole lot it would take a massive
massive undertaking a massive Army for
us to win Michigan
yeah but is Michigan one of the
principal States we got to win 2024 it's
one of only six or seven that matter
yeah and you know you look at what they
did with with the election law in
Michigan basically making it impossible
for us to overcome cheating there uh
manipulation thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time